[Musique]
assister à des concerts ou regarder un
match à plus de 1000 personnes
ce sera normalement possible à partir du
9 juin prochain à condition d'avoir un
passage me taire les députés de la
commission des lois ont donné leur feu
vert hier soir
mais l'examen du texte doit se
poursuivre jeudi en commission avant son
passage à l'assemblée nationale lundi
pourquoi voulez pas de gel tout le monde
accepte ça me pourrit les mains bonsoir
michel sardou bien les loin là je ne
touche pas même ses lois puis je suis
vacciné donc va très bien double des
deux doses les deux doigts et du bon du
finder
mais ils sont tous bien michel non si
ils sont où mais rien n'y fait
à singapour le gouvernement joue la
carte du clip déjanté pour promouvoir la
vaccination contre le communisme m
messi
je dis boby
vieux siècle m'emmerde oui mais cette
époque ça vous l'écrivez net oui que on
est interdit de tout je soutiendrai non
mais avouez oui alors vous avez dit
pourquoi vous à lisser société mais à ce
qu'il ya au moins des trucs positifs
dans ce siècle
la scène finale de blanche-neige mise en
scène dans un univers comme on dit chez
disney cette scène finale est l'objet de
toutes les critiques rappelez-vous
blanche neige est morte endormi à jamais
le prince rien à elle et dépose sur ses
lèvres un baiser qui la ramène à la vie
hélas hélas si ce baiser sauve l'héroïne
de nos jeunes années ce baiser est aussi
non consentie et d'un baiser non
consenti à une agression sexuelle il n'y
a qu'un pas il aurait peut-être fallu la
réveiller avant de signer un contrat
acceptes tu que je t'embrasse tu signes
on ne renvoie ça on fait une application
sur internet pour s'assurer que c'est
bien toi qui a signé et ensuite je
pourrai d'embrasser on n'embrasse pas
une morte sans lui demander son avis il
faut revenir un jour mon prince viendra
je pense surtout qu'à ce jour il ne
viendra plus le prince il restera chez
lui comme ça il n'aura plus d'ennuis
c'est peut-être d'ailleurs ce
qu'espèrent les féministes radicales
un monde sans prince je ne veux pas être
un charmant il agresse sexuellement
blanchement
l'annoncé chinoise
notez comme telle elle ne dit pas oui
dans quelle d'inongo rien dire c'est ce
que dit elle ne peut rien dire donc elle
n'est pas en état de dire oui d'eau
qu'il la laisse tranquille
je signale au passage que dans la belle
et la bête le chandelier lumière qui un
fort accent français aussi est un
véritable séducteur qui pose des yeux
concupiscent sur le postérieur de plus
mais ça c'est dans wikipédia dénoncé des
dons je dénonce aujourd'hui moralement
il est venu le prince
[Musique]
je savais que j'allais pose cette
question je réponds mais c'est pas savez
ce qu'est ce que vous êtes en train de
me montrer lâché intérêts josiane
d'accord avec moi j'ai pas quand même la
plus belle période de 18 mois je l' ai
connu la belle période
j'allais vite et picoler au préfet de
fumée partout
bon
[Applaudissements]
je vous emmène à la découverte de la
bière du futur c'est une brasserie
américaine qui s'appelle la brasserie
nous belgium qui s'est amusé à imaginer
quel goût pourrait avoir la bière dans
une cinquantaine d'années est le
résultat le voilà ça s'appelle la torche
heures ce qu'on pourrait traduire par
terre brûlée fidèles à leur réputation
les britanniques n'ont pas fait semblant
en matière de lever de coude depuis la
réouverture des terrasses le 12 avril
gardien révisions ont été dépassés
explique le patron d'un des plus grands
groupements de jeunes du client rien non
plus grand que moi en tout cas les
fournisseurs ne peuvent pas suivre à la
demande en houblon a été trois fois plus
élevé que les prévisions les plus
optimistes la bière du futur sera
imbuvable désolé regardez les têtes des
pauvres cobaye à qui on a fait goûter
cette bien vous allez voir ils ont pas
l'air de passer un super moment
alors je vous rassure cette bière avait
pas frelaté elle est complètement que
veulent c'est juste qu'elle est dégueu
en fait voilà tout ça c'est à cause du
changement climatique parce qu'en fait
ce qu'ils ont fait c'est qu'ils ont créé
une recette en tenant compte des
contraintes liées au réchauffement de la
planète
le voile se déroule bien
c'est très très bien je vais très
malheureux un baleineau voyez un petit
bug qui s'étaient égarés dans le port de
sète en médoc alors c'est dangereux
parce qu'alors normalement ils évoluent
dans le pacifique ce cétacé de 15 mois
qui a traversé la mer du maroc jusqu'à
l'italie pour rejoindre les côtes
françaises et les services de protection
et de secours se sont mobilisés pour
l'empêcher de rentrer dans le port où
c'était beaucoup trop dangereux pour lui
et grâce à leurs efforts et bien il a pu
repartir en méditerranée
[Applaudissements]
des géants dans une maison de poupée
voilà l'avis de beaucoup d'internautes
en découvrant la photo officielle de la
visite de joe et jill biden
chez l'ancien président américain jimmy
carter et son épouse rosalynn un cliché
moquer et détourner cet effet d'optique
est vraisemblablement dû à l'objectif
grand-angle utilisé par le photographe
pour que tout le monde soit sur la photo
dans cette petite pièce avec peu de
recul je suis pas prêt
si tu m'énerves pourquoi tu me regardes
à chaque fois je m'habille jamie chung
young en faillite
c'est fatiguant donné ça fait ça fait
trois mois qu'on est ensemble tu me dis
jamais que je suis bon on m'a dit quand
j'étais jeune une fois que je
ressemblais sophie marceau rabbo moi je
vois pas l'eau calme toi chérie genre
c'est quoi en fait je te dis à 20
minutes que ton brushing était jolie
donc tu veux quoi en fait à chaque fois
que tu changes de paires de chaussettes
faut aussi que je te dis que tu es beau
s'appelle de l'abus de confiance
d'origine je veux m'excuser parce que
ont normalement au brief les auditeurs
avant le passage yagg
il ya une règle vous ne la connaissez
pas et vous ne font rien
quand sylvie noachovitch parle quoi
qu'elle dise on ferme sa gueule voilà
c'est la règle d'or que non mais je vous
en prie moi-même joliette depuis 21 ans
elle a le droit de dire ce qu'elle veut
qu'il commençait à l'aigle est allé
stone commandes comme en gaz et eau
j'ai encore 30 de la corse analyse qui
est très intéressant ouais c'est très
bien ashton et ils tentent de par ce
qu'on peut lui couper le micro
alors je les vends du 301 euros faut
savoir que ça appartient aux parents
donc qui aurait probablement qu'il est
vendu 100 euros comme ça je vais garder
leur s donc je vais retourner dans les
caves je pense que je vais vite revenir
avec un de produits